hello everyone uh
please welcome martin durant with us and
martin is going to talk about all you
need is sar parallel access to remote hd
f5 tiff grip2 and others
this is going to be interesting talk
and uh a couple of things uh i want to
mention that this whole session is
governed by par data global coc
uh so please make sure that you are
there to coc and please don't violate
this user device i need to remove it and
the whole session has been recorded it
will be available to you
in the following day
over to you martin and could you please
give us short buy about yourself that
would be wonderful
okay we'll do thank you very much my
name is martin durant i work for
anaconda and have done for six years i'm
in the open source team
i work on desk file systems
file formats intake
and streams a few different
projects that you might have heard of
and today i'll be talking about czar and
accessing
data in the cloud that is not stored in
formats that are meant for the cloud
okay
so here's a
brief
contents page um
there are formats such as hdf5 now hdf5
i will mention multiple times it's the
first format that we started off with
but
the same applies for several other
formats
loads of data is stored in this format
it's been around for a long time it's
well established it's formalized in
various standard document
prescriptions and so lots of providers
of data like to store their array or
tabular data in hdf5 format
there are actually lots of
kinds of data format out there and they
might all be
binary efficient they might be
specialized to particular use cases
but they basically store arrays
now in the modern era
we have much more data than we can
possibly download more data than we can
fit into a simple laptop's memory so we
want to move
compute to data that is we want to use
resources in the cloud to work on data
in the cloud because the data is too
expensive to move around
there are formats for storing data that
do this very well and they do it well
because they have nice features such as
metadata that is separate from the data
itself and easy to understand the
ability to access chunks of the data in
parallel
the ability to make an object that
represents the data and pass it between
processes so that you can distribute
your compute without having to move data
around
they should be pluggable you should be
able to fetch the parts both in parallel
and concurrently that is to ameliorate
latency so these are all nice desirable
things that the established formats like
the hdf5 don't have so what can we do
about this
well an obvious thing you could do is to
transform your data into a modern format
for example look at the pangio forge
project that does this however it does
mean that you end up with a whole new
copy of your data it might be a more
optimized copy but it's still
duplicating the storage requirements
you could come up with some service that
can read the data locally and serve it
to those that wish to see it that means
you have to
invest in new infrastructure some kind
of query system you have to stand up new
stuff
or you could maybe for some very
specific use cases
code particular drivers particular
packages that can deal with that
specific type of data or you can do what
we're going to show in this particular
uh presentation which is to use tsar
that i will introduce and reference file
system which i'll also introduce
to
load the data from its native format in
a way that is friendly to cloud
processing
so i'm going to go into the detail of
how this actually works first of all
here is an hdf5 file and again different
types of binary storage have similar
properties in an hdfi file you have some
metadata this might be spread around the
file in various places here marked in
purple and you also have binary data
blocks these might also be interspersed
there might be one of them there might
be many of them they might be the same
size feature there's there's a whole lot
of different possibilities
now one of these binary blocks it
actually contains a c buffer it will be
a multi-dimensional contiguous block
this will be encoded filtered compressed
but basically it's just a binary block
there is some representation of a c
buffer and a c buffer is the same thing
but numpy understands it's the same
thing that all computing frameworks work
with
okay so that's the first piece of the
puzzle the second piece is the zar
package this is initially um a python
package but exists actually now for
several languages including java
javascript julia
some others
it has many of the features that we want
from a a cloud native
storage system you have metadata that is
stored in short pieces of json so you
can actually look at these and
understand them
the
chunks of a particular data set are
stored in a hierarchy so you can subset
to the particular array within a data
set just by walking down a file system
directory path within that directory you
have chunks you can access these chunks
individually they're separate files
and how these are encoded is very simply
specified in this separate package
called numcodex basically you can encode
you can compress with things like gzip
things we understand
and it's all specified in one place and
very easy to understand and finally
because i happen to be the author of sff
spec this is how i became involved in
tsar
it works well with fspec fspec is used
by medi-pi data well i'm going to
describe fspec in just a moment but the
fact that this works is a critical piece
so moving on to what fspec is it is a
library a python library that gives you
api access to storage systems across
many different storage backends which
might be local file system it might be
hdfs or something on your cluster it
might be cloud object stores like s3 or
google cloud storage it might be dropbox
there's quite a few of these
all of them have the same methods so
from the calling applications point of
view you don't need to know what that
storage system is it looks and behaves
the same
this means that you can now
access any of these storage storage
back-ends without having to worry about
it furthermore you can distribute the
fspec objects themselves on a cluster
that again is important if you're going
to distribute workloads across a cluster
and it comes with guarantees that you
can
request many files concurrently for high
latency systems such as again s3 or
google storage or azure
um and it comes with a whole load of
utilities that are that make it
convenient for people to use
it was initially designed for das but is
now used by many pi data projects
finally reference file system this is a
particular implementation for fspec and
it enables you to build a virtual file
system where each of the paths is
defined to be either some data
or a reference to a binary block that
lives somewhere else that somewhere else
is an arbitrary url you give an offset
and size within that url and you make
this
look as if it's a file within this file
system so now you have a way of
encapsulating random bits of binary data
within a file system all handled by
fspec
anything that can use fs spec will view
this as if it was a file system like
anything else like your local file
system
um crucially it's uh
that makes it um usable by anything in
the pi data system as i say
and it comes with these nice benefits of
being able to
read in parallel and concurrently which
are
two sides of the
of the um same coin but uh you can ask
about that later that said the
difference is subtle
um and it comes with uh some extra
features that i don't need to go into uh
at this point we can ask about that at
the end
so a summary of the things that i've got
over here
with this stack tsar is able to
open
a reference file system
it can access binary chunks that are
spread over many files
many different file systems possibly
and it views them as if they were
a
set of files within a particular
directory hierarchy which is exactly
what zar expects for it to be able to
construct a data set
now that now we can pass this data set
off to x-ray and we can process it with
das or
whatever and everything just works the
only thing that you need to know the
only thing that is missing from this is
how do you generate the mapping from
path to binary block in some url
and that is all handled by a package
called cachunk
this is uh the new name this is recently
released so uh we're going to go a
little bit into what it does and then
i'll go over some
demonstrations of the final product
so what kechunk does it for for uh
several file types we handle hdf grib
fits and tiff at the moment those are
the things that that can be used
it reads through those files and for the
various arrays that are encoded it reads
the metadata about what that array is
like its shape is d type how it's
encoded how it's compressed
and it constructs a json file that
contains this information
so that uh this is the reminder of the
picture that we had before we have a cra
buffer that lives somewhere
with some encoded in compression inside
this hdf5 file now you have a picture
that's like this kuchunk fills in the
piece that's in the central box here
it figures out the attributes of a given
array it figures out the types of a
given array and stores them in the kind
of json that czar expects
and then it encodes each of the chunks
so that they appear at a particular path
location here the time slash zero time
slash one are two chunks of this array
and czar understands this structure and
it knows that those chunks belong to the
same array and so it can operate on them
in parallel when you do a read
furthermore you can
combine many chunks from many files uh
concatenate them together or what
whatever kind of merging procedure you
need and construct
a
an ensemble json that points to all of
these chunks together so that you can
produce a single tsar data set that now
works over multiple files in this case
uh this is just for example we if we
have several hdf5 files on the left here
that
because i'm lazy with copy and paste all
happen to have the same structure that's
not necessarily the case
the task that chunk does is to figure
out for each of the chunks in each of
those files where does it live within
the directory hierarchy that zar needs
so that you can construct an ensemble
data set across all of them
now you can view
many files potentially and we have an
example here where we'll have millions
of files
and they all live within a single
sliceable
object that you can then pass to desk
for distributed parallel computing
okay so i have a demo and i will show
this in a moment first i just comment
that this demo was recorded because it
seemed like a really bad idea to try to
do network traffic at the same time as
i'm broadcasting
via zoom so please forgive me but it was
my first take so it's
semi live now i will press play and with
look you can actually hear this let me
know if the audio isn't working and then
i can narrate it live
so i will show you three simple examples
of aggregate data sets produced by
cajunc
and using fspec
to
pipe their data through tsar and
we're going to see what that looks like
here
so the first one the first case we're
talking about fits files which is an
astronomy specific data format you don't
need to know too much of the
details here indeed the point of all of
this is that different binary file
formats are going to feel very similar
once we've put them through the process
so let's have a look at this
now i'm just going to execute some
things and not go into too much detail
at first i'll show you some little
detail of what's happening here in a
moment
we've opened the data dataset and it
looks like this
here we have um some fairly large
coordinates this is x-array by the way
for those that aren't used to seeing
that
and we can see that the total size the
effective in-memory size if we wanted to
load this whole data set comprising of a
few variables into memory would be some
400 gigabytes or so so too big for my
computer to download but not amazingly
massive
so how did this work well let's go into
the goods just for a moment here so i
say um fspec is the glue that brings all
of these things together let's look at
the target
files now these live on google storage
that's what gcs is here and they're in a
few folders
if we look inside one of these folders
it's a bunch of fits files
now we can view these fits files using
the reference file system like so
again this is referencing just a
particular json file containing
all of the details of all of the files
that it's pointing to
and having loaded that we can treat this
thing like a file system we can list its
contents here are some directories
and we can look at the contents of one
of these directories these are just
normal file system like commands
and we can look at the contents of one
of these files this is a block of json
of the sort that zar needs in order to
be able to load the array and we can
look at one of the actual references you
can see this is pointing so for this
path within this virtual file system
it's pointing at this original file on
google storage and here is the offset
and size of that file so that is how we
get a binary chunk out of this
so those are the goods and up here we
made this
dataset object so what can we do with
this well we can use it like you would
for any other
x-ray object we can view this thing
this will pop up in just a second now it
is downloading some 20 megabytes for
each of these frames but you can see
this is a single view over the whole
300 400 gigabyte data set i can choose a
data point and if you look carefully
after a moment the picture updates and
the sun will go around nice and slowly
this is solar data by the way i didn't
even mention because again the same
mechanism will work for astro data as
you see here and also for the different
file formats so let's try a second one
this one i have
preloaded some things because some of
the
elements of this notebook take a while
to
happen
but this is again using the similar kind
of process in this case i've written it
out longhand this is a fairly
complicated cell here but i'll talk
about that in a moment it only takes a
few seconds to complete and then we have
this data set loaded that looks like
this again it has uh some coordinates
several data variables each of these
data variables has various attributes
that we could look at
uh we have some dimensions uh it's a
full x-ray data set with lots and lots
of detail and the
virtual size of this that is the size it
would take in memory if we wanted to
load the whole thing into data set
into uh arrays would be 260 and this
time we're talking terabytes so pretty
big
now it's in fact so big that um we won't
need a helper function here to be able
to tell us where in this data set is
there actually data because it turns out
a fair amount of this coordinate space
is empty just filled with nuns so there
is some code here to do that and i'm not
going to go over it for the sake of time
and just skip over it and show you the
visualization tool which again this is a
custom thing you'll see what this does
in a moment when it pops up
this is what it looks like
so make that fit
so
this panel on the left here tells me
where in my data set i have data for the
particular set of parameters i have
selected here so this is satellite
imaging or in fact satellite coherence
data if i go to a different polarization
you can see that different parts of the
map are selected if i go to a different
season or a different coherence in fact
this one seems to be fairly well
populated so if we zoom in for example
on hawaii and i click
let's say on here
after a moment this is pretty big data
we have some
nice visualization of rookie terrain on
hawaii you can zoom out a little bit
here and re-render
and here you can see
quite complicated volcanic features so
that's pretty cool again this is
satellite imaging
of the earth
and some
well many terabytes let's say but i can
browse it freely here
and i can
look through the data as i wish and it's
really pretty quick i have an ensemble
overview of the whole data set in one go
in this case we're dealing with whole
geotiff files so this was case two
and finally i will look at
another one this is actually hdf files
in this case we're looking at chunks
within hdf files so i'll do the same
thing as i did again we have a fairly
complicated cell here that's going to
load this
um x-ray data set
but once we've done it
and this takes a
best part of a minute to do
once we've done it we will have a
reference to some 370 000 hdf files and
actually
we'll be pointing specifically at chucks
within these 370 000 hdf files
so we'll just let that complete we can
sit around for a moment
um once again this is rather complicated
and uh
people will not want to have to type out
all of these parameters but uh we we can
probably cope with that so come back to
that in a moment so here it is it
arrived after some uh
that's it 40 seconds ish
and the size of this thing again this is
equivalent in memory size is either 60
some terabytes for the whole data set or
8 terabytes for any one of these
variables
and i can
do some kind of i'm just going to
execute this for the sake of time we
don't have too much today
i will show you that we can plot
some particular part of this data set
this will take a few seconds to come up
to
and visualize the data be able to browse
slices from within data
in fact this is running remotely i could
have started up a das cluster to be able
to do some heavy duty processing on this
data but this is live and this is
interactive so i can zoom in and in a
second it updates all of this data this
is all um
rivers and waterways and i i can
re-render it
and browse through the data as i wish
and i could actually do some heavy-duty
analysis on this
so
okay
so i will show you three
so uh
we are getting towards time so i'll end
with some uh final thoughts which is
that uh
this gives us a window into data that is
in archival formats that don't behave
well uh not built for
cloud systems but we can
essentially do
as well as if we transformed all of the
data into tsar which is meant for doing
exactly that and
but we don't have to we can use the
original data without copying it we can
furthermore get ensemble views uh
aggregate data sets over many inputs
and as a final point i um i mentioned
pangio forge as a way of copying data
pangoforge might it will be a good place
to actually run
the process of generating these
reference files to um
look up pangio forge i don't have time
to go into what that is now
there are some things that should be
born in mind
um when you do this you are stuck with
whatever chunking the original files had
because you're not changing anything
it's staying in the same place there are
some limited things that you can do but
basically you you cannot reformat the
data is what it is
um
the
manner in which i i mentioned a couple
of times the code that it takes to load
this is rather more complex that you
might be used to so the intent is that
we will build intake catalogs so that
the users of these supermassive data
sets don't need to know those details it
will just work it'll be hidden inside an
intake catalog
this requires a couple of small fixes in
intake x-ray that i mean to do next week
it will be quick i promise
and the finally you do need to at some
point understand the data that you're
working with you need to scan it you
need to figure out
where the different pieces of that data
how they fit together we
have put a certain amount of work into
automating that but we haven't covered
all possible use cases yet we're getting
there
and finally if for the future this now
works for some binary formats as as i
already mentioned we had tiff there we
had uh
fits we had hdf and also we have an
example for grib and there are other
things that it would work for as soon as
we can make the small pieces of code
that it takes to scan them
this is all coded in python but the
output spec those json files
are architecture language agnostic you
could use them anywhere there is one
example i'm aware of doing all of this
in using tsar in javascript
the storage is json json doesn't scale
amazingly well to enormously big files
so when the reference set itself
gets reasonably big we might have to
come up with something else particularly
we might not want to load the whole
thing into memory at once
and we have some ideas about how we
don't necessarily have to scan every
file maybe we can know where in a target
data set
a particular chunk should live by the
for example the path names of the
original data it's quite common to
encode details about the data in the
path names themselves so we should use
that rather than having to scan unless
we really have to
and then finally this idea was presented
here because it's all about tsar for
array data but actually you could do
this kind of thing for other sorts of
data where the path matters
such as
parquet
or where it's really important to be
able to find the blocks within some
other file for example tar compression
is one
or even csv when you have embedded new
lines in csv
records then you can't necessarily just
jump to some part of a massive csv and
be sure that the first new line that you
meet is actually a new record you can
only do that by scanning the whole file
so this would be a way to scan it once
store the references and then for the
future you can now access it in parallel
and that's it a few minutes for
questions here are some collaborators
and also a special thanks to maxine
liquid who helped with the data browser
tool that you saw for the satellite
imagery
thank you martin for the presentation uh
i think we have a couple of questions
for you in the chat
so i'm gonna start with the first one uh
which is is a roadmap of what file
formats are being considered for future
implementation they don't see anything
in the docs which by the way are great
uh we have some ideas it depends on
where the best use cases come from so
for example i would love to do this for
astronomical data i already mentioned
fits but it was a very simple case for
fits
and
fits file format is only used by
astronomers so it's not very
far-reaching but it could be interesting
another obvious one would be various
medical imaging formats like dicom and
nifty or other image formats like uh
even jpeg you could use often do have
very large
sets of jpeg files by the thousands in
directories that might be
readable as a single aggregate data set
but yeah common tell us what you think
should be done
um writing the pieces to scan files and
find binary blocks is not difficult if
there already is a python interface to
that kind of file
uh we have another question uh which is
if data set grows over time say day over
day can the scan be done in a way that
only has to process the new data
uh yes and no so um for the cases that
we are doing in pangea forge the idea is
to scan the individual files usually
if it if your data set is growing it
means new files usually
so to keep the references for the
individual files somewhere temporary and
those reference sets are much smaller
than the files that they are references
into and then you only need to do the
new files when they arrive and
re-aggregate into a global data set so
that's one part of it the other is i
mentioned that currently we store these
references in json but it could be
something else like sql lite would
would
really lend itself to being able to
update references and add references as
they come in but we haven't done that
yet
all right thank you for the answer
uh seems like martin we are almost at
the time and
i would like to thank you for coming
here and you know presenting your work
and it was a pleasure to have you
okay thank you
you